معنى الانمي الناكيه العقيد يوري هنا
المتحدث باسم القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه نرحب بك العقيد هناك دعنا نبدا
بتطورات المدنيه المتعلقه
ليست المره الاولى التي تستهدف ولكن ما
المختلف هذه المره وما اذا كان هناك رسائل
مراد ايصالها من خلال هذا الاستهداف
مسائكم طيب بالطبع اوديس تهاجم لعده مرات
من قبل
القوات الروسيه بالصواريخ والمسيارات
الروسيه بالمرات السابقه كان العدو يستخدم
ذخيره مثل
22 وفي هذه المره استخدموا كليبر
ومسيرات شاهد اما ما استخدموها اليوم
عفوا اما ما استخدمناه اليوم من انظمه
الدفاع دمرت كل المسيرات وثماني صواريخ
كاليبر هذه الصواريخ ندمرها بمعدات الدفاع
الجويه المعتاده اما الصواريخ الباليستيه
مثل خائف 22 وصواريخ اونيكس للاسف ليس
لدينا ما يكفي من الانظمه
لاسقاط هذه الصواريخ ان روسيا في العامه
الماضي
عفوا روسيا في الماضي استخدمت الجوع
للقضاء على الاوكرانيين وكانت تحاول ان
تضغط الان على اوكرانيا بالمجال الاقتصادي
وهي تحاول ان تدمر البنيه التحتيه للموانئ
في اوديسا وميكالوريا وفي الموانئ في نهر
الدنائي ولذلك هنا كل ما يجب ان نعرفه عن
روسيا انها تدمر او تحاول ان تدمر البنيه
التحتيه للموانئ وكثيرا تصيب المباني
السكانيه وطيور دور العباده
والكثير من المناطق حيث المدنيين وكل
الاثار التي ترونها الان على شاشتكم هي
اثار
هي اثار لعمل
الفاعليه التي
سقوط الشظايا على بعض المناطق السكانيه
الان كيف تطالب بان المانيا والولايات
المتحده بتزويدها بصواريخ بعيده
المدى ما الذي قد تحققه يعني امتلاك او
يحققه امتلاك اوكرانيا لمثل هذه الصواريخ
من المانيا والولايات المتحده على الارض
في ساحه القتال تحديدا
نحن حصلنا من شركائنا من فرنسا ومن
بريطانيا على صواريخ مجنحه وهي صواريخ
تستخدم روسيا مسائل لها منذ بدايه الحرب
كاليبر 22 التي تستخدمها في استهداف
اوديسا والان لدينا ستورم
ونحن نتمنى اننا سنحصل من المانيا على
صواريخ
المانيه وان الولايات المتحده سوف تتخذ
قرارات بتسليمنا صواريخ
الباليستيه ما نحتاجه وما الهدف الذي نضعه
لاجل الحصول على هذه الاسلحه نريد تحرير
جميع اراضينا وحتى نقوم بهذا يجب ان ندمر
الاعمال اللوجستيه للعدو يجب ان ندمر
مستودعات الذخيره عند العدو ان
ونستهدف مراكز الاعمال اللوجستيه التي
تستخدم
للامدادات والامدادات قواتها بالوقود
والذخيره ومختلف المواد التي تساعدهم في
الاستمرار في هذا العدوان ان اوكرانيا
لا تريد ان تستخدم هذه الاسلحه الغربيه في
هجمات على الاراضي الروسيه بل فيها هجمات
على الاراضي المحتله الروسيا الان وهذا
دينيسكو
وبعض ضواحي خاركوف وايضا القرد هذه هي
الصواريخ التي عفوا هذه المواقع التي
تصلها هذه الصواريخ مثل
نتائج فعاله جدا باستخدام هذه الصواريخ
ولكن اذا حصلنا على صواريخ طاووس بعيده
المدى وانظمه ارسمس هذه
ستكون عمليات نوعيه ومستوى جديد
ونتائج افضل بكثير
شكرا جزيلا لك من كيف العقيد يوري هناك
المتحدث باسم القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه